Speaker 1: I want to start today by talking
about Texas.
Texas is a state that for so many years we
keep hearing this is the year that Texas might
change.
This is the year that due to demographic shifts,
it might no longer be a red state.
This is the year a Democratic candidate might
win the presidential election in 2020.
It was theorized that maybe Joe Biden could
it didn't ultimately happen.
And we've been talking more and more about
Texas, including yesterday on the bonus show,
which I hope I mean, the bonus show at this
point, award winning and world famous.
If you're not getting the bonus show, what
are we doing, folks?
Yesterday on the bonus show, I told you, I'm
very happy to hear that Democrat Byetta O'Rourke
is looking very strongly, as the kids say
these days, at running for governor in Texas
in 2022 against the incumbent Republican governor,
Greg Abbott.
Greg Abbott is horrible.
I mean, really just a horrible person and
has been an absolute disaster for Texas.
And I'm just as thrilled to tell you today
that Greg Abbott's approval rating is continuing
to collapse and crater and decline, as it
should, based on what he has done as governor
of Texas.
And this could shape up to be a major win
for Democrats in next year's midterm.
So let's quantify this first and then we'll
talk more qualitatively.
What are the numbers in Texas?
Well, Greg Abbott's job approval is now down
to just 45 percent.
This is a Republican governor in a Republican
state that increasingly has purple elements
to it.
For sure, 54 percent of Texans say the state
is going in the wrong direction.
Before covid, Abbott's approval was 59 percent.
Fifty nine, it's now 45 percent, that's a
decline of 14 percentage points.
Look at how much of a disaster Abbott's ideology
and leadership have been for Texas uncovered.
He's been on the side of the virus, quite
frankly.
He's been on the side of opposing ever really
closing much of anything.
His lieutenant governor, Dan Patrick, famously
went on TV and like was it May of twenty twenty?
It was very early June maybe, and said we've
got to keep things open, folks, and is willing
to sacrifice herself for the good of the economy,
by which he meant, of course, the stock market.
The Abbott administration has been on the
side of opposing masking requirements and
making them more difficult to pass.
The Abbott administration has been opposing
vaccination requirements and or making them
more difficult to put in place.
And Texas deaths.
Are spiking pretty badly, this has been one
of the worst run states on covid period under
the vague and almost meaningless and satirical
at this point heading of freedom and liberty.
So that's covid total disaster.
But then look at energy.
They love to brag in Texas, Republicans do
about we've got this big, bad independent
electrical grid.
We're not linked to any other states, including
any blue states.
We do our own thing.
We do our own generation.
And but we don't need anybody else.
And thanks to that very system, last winter,
Texas experienced major blackouts.
They tried to blame it on frozen wind farms.
And of course, we debunked that total and
complete humiliation for their liberty minded
electrical grid this past summer due to the
heat.
Texas, I mean, this summer.
What I mean is a couple of months ago, Texas
was going in and just adjusting people's thermostats
to try to reduce electrical demand.
Now, to be clear, the customers that had that
happened, they did opt into that.
But it's not common that it actually has to
be done by the electrical company, just one
disaster after another.
And as I said yesterday, I'm very excited
about betterer, challenging Greg Abbott.
This is building my belief even more that
the twenty, twenty two midterms could be some
of not only the most interesting from an observer
standpoint, but some of the most consequential
midterms in a long time.
Abbott's approval rating should be collapsing.
He and his administration have caused unnecessary
suffering and needless death.
And now in 14 months, Greg Abbott could be
held accountable for it.
There are going to be important races in these
midterms at every single level.
Now, of course, every member of the House
is up for reelection as they are every two
years.
One third of senators may be in your state.
One third are up for reelection.
Many governors are up for reelection.
Or we may even have open seats as far as governors
are concerned.
And then, of course, state Senate, state House,
they're going to keep trying to take over
school boards.
We're going to talk about school boards a
little bit later on in today's program.
Really a ton that is going to be on the ballot.
And in a sense, it's a referendum on Trump
ism as well.
And we've talked about why, if the Trump acolytes
all get reelected or most of them do or Trump
endorse candidates, when it will further the
grasp that Trump ism has on the Republican
Party, it will likely encourage Trump to run
in 2012, 2024.
If the opposite happens, it may dissuade Trump
from running in 2004.
It may push the Republican Party away from
Trump ism.
So we will see now to go back to Greg Abbott
momentarily.
He's been a huge disaster.
He's failed everywhere, and yet he and the
Republicans may still run in Texas on Democrats
are going to take your guns if they win, and
that actually could be enough to win in Texas.
They could do that and they could end up winning
if we don't take this seriously.
But we're going to have plenty of time to
talk about Beto O'Rourke's candidacy as we
get closer to the midterms.
I keep telling people on the bonus show, in
my discussions with YouTube, with our YouTube
rep, it seems more and more like the expectation
is the midterm build is going to start earlier,
often doesn't start until late April into
May, fully expecting by late February, mid-March
at the latest late March, these midterms are
going to get going.
The Texas race with better O'Rorke believed
to be set to challenge Greg Abbott.
Going to be a big part of that.
And we're going to be covering that as well.
We also will be covering what is this building
and continued sort of civil war within the
Republican Party.
And that's what I want to
talk about next.